es ist der deutschen liebstes tier das
sparschwein sogar ein denkmal wurde ihm
errichtet auf sparsamkeit ist der
deutsche wohlstand aufgebaut
das weiß auch der münzhändler auch
nichts dann kann ich auch nichts große
landschaften das sparen ist tief
verankert in der deutschen seele eine
süße tugend natürlich in diesen zeiten
immer sehr schwierig natürlich aber
nicht eine immer leute sichert sachen
und darum hat man natürlich auch noch
das geld war von hat auf dem sparbuch
beides gehen das beiseite legen für
schlechte zeiten
das steckt den deutschen im blut schon
seit jahrhunderten wird gespart
der wirtschaftshistoriker werner
abelshauser sieht die gründe für die
spar mentalität in der bewegten
deutschen geschichte dreißigjähriger
krieg und vielstarterin man musste auf
alle schicksalsschläge vorbereitet sein
und das bedeutete dass man in der lage
sein musste bei krankheit bei dem tod
wichtiger familienmitglieder bei der
ausbildung von kindern die man dann
wegschickte irgendwo um etwas zu lernen
da musste man schon in der lage sein aus
dem geldvermögen rasch zugreifen zu
können
vor 200 jahren dann die ersten
sparbücher staatlich gefördertes sparen
selbst die ärmsten sollten was
zurücklegen sinnvoll als es noch kein
sozialsystem gab das geld der deutschen
es vermehrte sich ohne dass sie ein
risiko eingehen mussten die deutsche
wirtschafts kultur ausdrücklich also das
haben auch die ökonomen im in abgrenzung
zu dem britischen beispiel so gesehen
im kaiserreich war ausdrücklich nicht
auf börse und spekulation hin orientiert
sondern auf kooperation und nachhaltig
immer wieder wurde das ersparte
entwertet durch weltwirtschaftskrise die
hyperinflation oder währungsreformen
doch nichts konnte den sparwillen der
deutschen brechen große spa ideologie
kam eigentlich erst nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg in den 50er jahren wo man ja
nun alles neu anschaffen musste oder
nicht alles aber vieles neu anschaffen
muss wird und die das kaufen das
konsumieren auf kredit nicht sehr
populär
bis heute werden schon die kleinsten
aufsparen gemünzt das geld gehört gut
angelegt auf die bank sicher und
risikofrei auch wenn es kaum noch zinsen
gibt und das ersparte wegschmilzt ein
notgroschen muss sein dass man nicht
mehr ausgibt wie man hat das sollte
einem schon mit dem einmaleins rechnen
sollte einen das schon beigebracht
werden und wenn man einigermaßen
berücksichtigt dann kommt man nicht auf
die sollseite sondern bleibt auf der
habenseite
und wenn es dem schwein dann doch mal an
den kragen geht dann muss es schon für
etwas ganz besonderes sein